and seeing so many comments of people
asking to cover more scary videos so I
was like all right I think I have one
finally recommended our way that I
really want to check out this comes from
the channel nooks top five five ghosts
caught on camera poltergeist these
videos go to crap out of me California
is slowly on its way to weirdly
reopening again the gyms are opening
back up this week probably gonna start
getting some guests in here soon in the
meantime we still got John with us get
ready because once the world opens back
up
it'll just be girl you gonna be no more
John John cringes at everything so maybe
he'll be more fun than the woman for
these videos on camera
the most haunted hotel in Texas the
minger hotel was built in 1859 in San
Antonio Texas Mina was constructed on
the old battle grounds of the Texas
Battle of the Alamo so during the Civil
War Hotel was converted into a hospital
for wounded and dying soldiers with a
history like that it's not surprising
that the hotel is considered a hotbed
for paranormal activity
over the years hotel staff members and
guests have had countless strange
supernatural encounters but some even
claim to have seen tortured ghostly
faces peering back in them
when they look into the hotel's mirrors
a meager hotel has been dubbed the most
haunted hotel in Texas my paid and his
wife stayed overnight at the infamous
major hotel in hopes of witnessing some
of the supposed supernatural activity
they got their wish I'm here at the
Manor Hotel I think that's how you say
it linger waiting some money came across
the street to get some playing cards
nothing yet walk up and down the halls
in here pretty nice hotel though the
flatscreen it's two closets there's one
the closets
[Music]
lots of space also that's face
[Music]
why would you do this
[Music]
hello Mike
hello
yeah
or you have Mike
no [ __ ] no no no no no no wait I
gotta wash this back
Zurich hidden cut there when you turn
the light off I feel like they're
they're easily good
oh my god I don't believe it so is this
a ghost caught on camera did a
poltergeist rearrange their luggage you
be the judge
get out YouTube moto vlogger vroom-vroom
Dana is far from a ghost hunter stop
believer in the paranormal however he
does sometimes ride his motorcycle out
to deserted or abandoned places
occasionally crashes into ghost house in
the middle of nowhere when odd things
start to happen with that creepy guy I
was like what though that first designer
he can seems to be thrown at Dana
he thinks it's a little strange but
otherwise doesn't really pay it much
mind making that the can probably just
happened to fall from the decaying
ceiling rafters
oh my god that no no no no we have
goosebumps
suddenly a satellite dish comes crying
down at a spot where Dana had just been
standing I made it there you just be
falling apart
breakdown so is this a poser
mr. ghost common camera or maybe just a
homeless person who's living in the
building and trying to scare Dana away
okay that's pretty scary that you think
that's scary - hmm I mean it could just
be falling apart right a good shopper in
a supermarket in Tijuana Mexico shoppers
got a bit of a shock when things
suddenly turned a little creepy in the
canned-food aisle Supermarket CCTV
camera won't you see some odd
distortions begin to appear up and down
the aisle
does that even anything it's looking
about blur patches
but soon things get even more bizarre
how about the security cameras have this
music play the puke and slaughter and a
second later even more tumble from the
Shelf almost is it holy moly
comes to take a look and even the store
worker checks in they both dismiss the
strange occurrence and just walk away
because this thing that adheres leanin
poltergeist call on camera or is it just
a bizarre glitch in the CCTV camera
coupled with some poorly stacked can
good you decide
gone GM abandoned mental asylum in South
Korea is said to be one of the most
haunted places on earth the facility was
closed it had 1990s but no one knows
exactly why many local townspeople say
it was because the patients and even the
staff began to pass away from mysterious
causes the locals claimed that the
building is cursed
well cursed or not that didn't stop
youtuber kpop dolo from exploring gum
jam mental asylum with his girlfriend
Sarah Oh Shh
yes look at Sarah we don't open do you
see it
wait a minute
hello it would just like her I'm gonna
say hello you guys had never seen
everybody I hope he chose another class
let's do inside they find old patient
beds still in place or in doubt rooms
strangest of all Luke prints all over
the wall parkour is fairly uneventful
until kpop dolo sees this
[Music]
No thank you no thank you no thank you
[Music]
right now
[Music]
it's not just as white people to do this
[Music]
no this foreshadowing above that door
see it run man
now a closed door opening on its own may
not seem very scary but here's where
things get truly bizarre when examining
an earlier part of the video
kpop dolo panda's camera by the exact
same door as he is entering the building
the door is wide dolo claims that he or
his girlfriend touched the door between
the two shots oh my god top it all off
many YouTube calendars say that they can
see a scary ghostly face in the door as
he points his camera down the hallway
[Music]
but what do you see is this just a hoax
you decide no sleeker knees a video from
the morgues outdoor CCTV camera the
video showed footage of the stretchers
used to move bodies doing some moving of
their own
oh no and the static in the middle
[Music]
do
what
[Music]
whoa oh you don't be really creepy
forgotten backup yeah marination would
be that the specter is being moved by a
wire except this structure moves in
multiple directions back and forth and
to the side
so if wires were being used it would
require quite a few string pullers in
another clip from a different CCTV
camera angle we see a morgue worker go
to collect one of the stretchers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
like a scary cat like everybody not
gonna pay the deceased still attached to
these stretchers or is it just a prank
or a hoax
let me know what you think I'm gonna
come that is such a real reaction
Halloween everyone and see you next week
boy yeah it's kind of old video hey man
Halloween in July
whatever holy moly
those are good buzzer girls are creepy
we joke but you guys miss was like we
were just skipping through Instagram of
her friend Sarah edge like works with
40x and we're like aw damn references on
Facebook so I went some of our Instagram
is hurt
holy crap yeah we gotta ask her about
the legitimacy of this Hut oh my god
Sarah edges from 4dx and she's our
connect to there and oh wow that is so
surprising oh we got a you got an email
her after this so excited second career
is a ghost hunter that's so shocking
that's the biggest surprise oh it's a
truth I've never had this random friend
Papa's not even a youtuber something she
like works behind the scenes it's so
funny oh whoa weird
terrific alright well this is a really
great I mean nooks top 5 is like
excellent and putting these together
like composed like the editing style the
the footage of course the mood the mood
the narration they're always like very
entertaining inside just like a still
image and he's talking you know like he
really knows how to do these so great
job again so let's talk about some of
these alright she likes to write and she
says her big favorite genres horrors oh
just like find her in a tagged photo to
be like okay now we got time for about
ghosts on day yeah yeah there's gonna
ask us to move this out of the video the
first one in the hotel watching this
back I feel like they're easily could
have been a hitting cut there in the
darkness when you turn off the light but
this could just be like really clever
editing but yeah whenever you turn off a
light or something it's really easy to
have a hidden cut as it stands I'm gonna
give the credit to them it's a really
well-executed video even if it is fake
that's a really well-done V okay
has that found-footage enos she goes
over to the window turns back in the
closets back open there are beats in
here that maybe feel a little bit like
they're set up and punched a little cuz
it's like okay we're gonna set up the
door first and close it then we're gonna
go to the other closet so yeah there's
gonna happen to the other closet then
I'm gonna peace out from there and then
the first Clause it's gonna open again I
can see how this might be inauthentic
but it's still pretty freakin creepy
yeah I say I really had me going and
that's the charm of even a DIY ghost
video yeah I mean that's that's where I
always stand with these is even if it's
fake I do them credit for at least
having me be really scared and pulled
into it in the moment I wonder I always
compare it to whenever I've attended a
magic show there's always that person in
the audience who's like not that's where
the slip happened okay like they're
always not impress just can't enjoy the
show with that I I like this one I
thought he was really funny the dude on
the motorcycle but I really think you
just like look at this building it's
falling apart you know I think it just
happened to show up there on a day when
stuff was falling apart yeah if anything
this like the the satellite dish falling
is just a coincidence that he happened
to be there at that time the one that's
more creepy to me is the idea of the
spray paint can yeah that one falling
over that one feels more creepy because
it looks like it was just thrown at him
yeah yeah it was just like plucked there
and random yeah like the satellite dish
one is buildings falling apart
yeah you know yeah although that one
actually weirded me more just because
it's right in his line of where he was
walking so yeah looked like you know
almost you could say have been
malevolent spirit wanna drop it right on
his head or something
I'm sure the roof of that place is not
in good integrity at all but to fall
directly through you know you got to go
a little distance the video store one
it's easy to just kind of go well that
blur just might have happened a beat
like the blur meant nothing to me
when the blur was happening I had looks
like a camera glitch or it could be some
final cuts it's really easy to insert a
blur if you really want the items
falling over that is very I'm sorry
falling over yeah when they're like
stationary steady level yeah like the
extra ones falling twos on the far
right of it yeah yeah that part I mean
all of these I guess you could go wires
and stuff that is pretty eerie to me
whenever I just see stationary things
fall and there is no real like oh yeah
maybe the house is falling apart or
something like that because no wind is
gonna be strong enough to blow soup cans
oh yeah I don't know I kind of want to
just hit him Sarah and ask her about
that one here that'd bring her on an
inner yeah about the entire experience
because the door opening and closing
like that there's just little subtle
things that are very creepy it's like
it's impossible to win with these if
it's so subtle you could chalk it up to
here's how it could be staged right if
it's too big must be fake yeah you know
there's no way you could ever win with
these like if you're talking about an
asylum well where you have such a
concentration of harsh dark anguish
energy yeah you know III don't know cuz
part of me wants to believe and part of
me is like I you could easily doctored
this stuff but I feel like if I'm
speaking in a subjective place you know
a building like this especially is like
the most convincing place to me echoes
of that energy could still exist yeah I
mean I believe that call it post energy
after leaving the body call it spirits
whatever you want I believe there is
something that does exist
watching that moment and combined with
the foot see I'd want to see like the
full unedited version when he's walking
and then the doors closed if they have
like on his video like a very long
version where the door is open and that
take is that's the part that really
hammered it home but I'll give it to
them I'll say it's real give that one
I'll say it's real the gurney I feel
like the extreme version of that it's
important to be skeptical news I think
the extreme version of that could be you
could jerry-rigged it electronically
somehow there's some way I mean you can
get an RC you can get strings you can do
all kinds of stuff and I yeah I mean I
guess an RC would alleviate the point of
his about you need a bunch of strings
and a bunch of people pulling them to do
that but the footage with the guy looked
very bad said it for me that's exactly
like especially his reaction and I feel
like you would hear some noise if it is
an RC on it a security camera footage
with no electronic audio on it like that
it's easier to get away with but if
there's someone there and
just happens to move like yeah all right
cool message received I'm not gonna
force you anywhere you know on Abbi
gurney
that is fun this is fun all right well
nooks top five make sure to subscribe to
his channel as soon as you can't
subscribe the real rejects for more
thanks guys for encouraging us seriously
I was like seeing comments even looking
at our analytics like damn these like
random scary videos and more a lot of
people have been subscribing and
watching for these rides during hard
time this is very weird yeah yeah do you
think you'd be the opposite some people
like different kinds of fear I guess
during difficult times sardick hey let's
do up Lance door now Lance is a
firefighter so I imagine that you must
have been into some buildings that are
really scary you must have encountered
some very spooky stuff in your life dude
but right now Lance is getting ready to
embark on what is easily the scariest
thing in the world
oh no oh god the suspense is killing me
Lance are you okay baby Lance where are
you going what's going on oh no man it's
just so scary that level of commitment
you know I don't buy it let me see the
strings and then if you're if things go
wrong they take all your money mm-hmm
they take all your money I mean I've
seen it dude people are together for
look at Brad Pitt and Angelina Jolie
dating for like a decade they get
married like a year later their divorce
Houston Kutcher and Demi Moore it just
it's scary man yeah it's scary like you
are gonna do the scary it changes
relationships it's weird it's bizarre
you really are a brave human being
mm-hmm good luck Lance be safe don't let
her to kill you that's how most
marriages end so beware